auch der januar 2001 die französische
luftsicherheitsbehörde bka
veröffentlicht in paris ihren ersten
bericht über die sechs monate zuvor
abgestürzte concorde
ursache sei ein metallstreifen gewesen
der von einer anderen maschine
abgefallen war das kleine bauteil hat am
25 juli 2001 113 menschen in den tod
gerissen und den untergang des
legendären überschallflugzeuges
besiegelt
er konnte noch so was
zwar genauso spektakulär wie das
flugzeug selbst
ich hätte nie gedacht dass dieses
großartige flugzeug abstürzen könnte mit
modernster 3d animation analysieren wir
die umstände die zu der tragischen
katastrophe geführt haben
durch den einschnitt den druck und die
geschwindigkeit ist der reifen einfach
explodiert
das kerosin hat sich entzündet obwohl
das reifen stück den tank nicht
durchschlagen
pro sekunde sind 75 bis 100 liter
treibstoff entwichen der treibstoff hat
sich entzündet und eine gewaltige
flammen fontaine an der unterseite des
linken flügels ausgelöst es sah aus wie
ein riesiger flammenwerfer wie konnte es
zu der katastrophe kommen
[Musik]
sie hatten keine wahl sie mussten
abwägen
und warum war dieses unglück
unvermeidbar
die stadtbahn ist 45 meter breit und der
metallstreifen musste ausgerechnet dort
liegen wo die räder entlang wollten
das war ein pilotenfehler sie hatten
keine chance es war so ein
majestätisches flugzeug es ist mir
wirklich unbegreiflich wie es dazu
kommen konnte
einfach unglaublich da fehlen einem die
worte
wie konnte sich dieses meisterwerk der
technik der stolz von frankreich nur 120
sekunden nach dem start in ein tödliches
flammeninferno verwandelt
sobald sie abgehoben hatte war das
schicksal der concorde besiege
flughafen charles de gaulle im norden
von paris
es ist der 25 juli 2000 ein schöner
sommertag auf
dem größten flughafen frankreich
herrscht hochbetrieb hinter den kulissen
versuchen mitarbeiter und besatzungen
alle abflugzeiten einzuhalten
[Musik]
einer von ihnen ist der fluglotse die
lust der an diesem tag dienstag
[Musik]
eigentlich sollte ich morgens arbeiten
aber am tag davor hatte mich ein kollege
gefragt ob ich mit ihm tauschen könnte
deshalb war ich am nachmittag da
[Musik]
alles war wie immer ich hatte die start
und landebahnen im blick und sah mir den
plan für den tag
als ich zum vorfeld von air france
überschattet wurde gerade eine concorde
rausgeschoben
sonst fliegt die concorde einmal am tag
hin und zurück heute ist es jedoch schon
ihr dritter start ein sonderflug machen
bislang ist wie viele seiner kollegen
ein großer fan der concorde noch weiß er
nicht dass er an diesem 25 juli einen
tragischen flugzeugabsturz aus nächster
nähe miterleben wird
in die zusammenhänge besser verstehen zu
koennen reisen wir zur geburtsstunde des
überschallflugzeugs zurück
1961 das terminal olli süd des
flughafens paris audi wird eröffnet die
luftfahrt ist im umbruch vor allem im
bereich des militärs kampfjets werden
mit neuen technologien ausgestattet und
fliegen so schnell wie nie zuvor
belgrad ist damals noch kein concorde
pilot er schwärmt von diesem goldenen
zeitalter der luft hat
die 60er jahre waren toll wir haben uns
jedes jahr bei der luft schau von
branche alle neuheiten angesehen in den
60ern schien nichts unmöglich die
aufbruchstimmung war richtig ansteckend
damals nimmt eine fast verrückte idee
gestalt an flüge sind nun auch für die
breiten massen bezahlbar und man
überlegt militärtechnologie in der
zivilen luftfahrt einzusetzen
1960 fliegt man in nur acht stunden von
paris nach new york drei jahre zuvor
waren es noch 14 geht es womöglich sogar
noch schneller
damals kamen die ersten diesen flugzeuge
auf den markt die boeing 707 die dudleys
dc-8 die caravelle flug da schon drei
oder vier jahre
es gab militärjets die fastnacht zwei
doppelte schallgeschwindigkeit fliegen
konnten also um die 2000 300 km h es
ging immer höher schneller und weiter
die idee eines überschall
verkehrsflugzeug schien der gar nicht so
weit hergeholt
ein passagierflugzeug dass es mit einem
kampfjet aufnehmen kann eine monumentale
aufgabe für die ingenieure der großen
flugzeughersteller
frankreich und großbritannien nehmen die
herausforderung an sie wollen ein
flugzeug bauen das mitmacht zwei fliegen
kann
mach eins sind 1000 235 km h und macht
zwei 2000 250 km h so schnell fliegen
normalerweise nur patronen kugeln durch
die luft
es wäre das erste mal dass gewöhnliche
passagiere schneller fliegen könnten als
der schall aber im unterschied zu
kampfpiloten würden sie weder anti g
anzüge noch sauerstoffmasken tragen
dennoch sollten sie sich entspannt
zurücklehnen und beim flug eine zigarre
genießen können das war eine
unglaubliche vorstellung
das sogenannte concorde projekt hat
seinen preis
35 milliarden euro nach heutigem wert
die europäischen entwickler haben einen
ehrgeizigen plan die maschine soll in
nur acht jahren einsatzbereit sein also
1970 über 200.000 leute sind an dieser
herkulesaufgabe beteiligt es gilt
zahlreiche technische hürden zu
überwinden
[Musik]
sie stürzten sich in die arbeit als ob
sie nie etwas anderes gemacht hätten
aber ein überschallflugzeug zu bauen ist
kein kinderspiel
dennoch wird der prototyp nach nur
sieben jahren entwicklungsarbeit am
zweiten märz 1969 vorgestellt
an jenem tag erwarten die entwickler
voller spannung den jungfernflug am
flughafen toulouse blagnac
weil der
großregion anbieter
gehört
der jungfernflug dauert nur 27 minuten
doch er hat das wichtigste bewiesen die
concorde fliegt sicher
[Musik]
januar 1976 der erste kommerzielle flug
der concorde
[Musik]
nach der erfolgreichen premiere 76
glaubten alle daran dass die concorde
ein erfolg werden würde
schließlich konnte sie wie versprochen
mit mach zwei von paris nach new york
fliegen
die concorde ist nun weit mehr als ein
überschallflugzeug sie ist ein symbol
[Musik]
man könnte das europäische concorde
projekt mit der amerikanischen mond
lande mission vergleichen
schließlich war es eine gewaltige
herausforderung ein sicheres
verkehrsflugzeug mit
überschallgeschwindigkeit zu entwickeln
[Musik]
die ingenieure der nachkriegszeit sind
über sich hinausgewachsen
sie haben mit diesem flugzeug ein
technisches meisterwerk geschaffen
sowohl auf französischer als auch auf
britischer seite
[Musik]
die concorde bricht alle rekorde
sie ist atemberaubende 2200 kilometer in
der stunde schnell und das in bis zu
18.000 metern flughöhe
die concorde ließ alle anderen
verkehrsflugzeuge hinter sich die
meisten maschinen fliegen nur auf 9.000
bis 12.000 metern höhe die concorde
hatte dort oben also freie wahl
zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
luftfahrt überquert ein flugzeug in
knapp drei stunden und 20 minuten den
atlantischen ozean
man konnte um 9 uhr morgens die concorde
nehmen um vormittags einen vertrag in
new york zu unterschreiben gegen 22 uhr
landete man wieder auf dem schilde
gaulle und hatte den halben tag in new
york verbracht
die concorde gilt als ebenso sicher wie
schnell niemand glaubt dass dieses
wunderwerk der technik jemals abstürzen
könnte
25 juli 2014 uhr flughafen schädigung
die concorde f btsc sollten 15 uhr bei
der flugkontrolle dreht jedoch ein
problem auf ein triebwerk style muss
ausgetauscht werden
wegen eines problems mit der schubumkehr
kam es zu einer verspätung
der kapitän hatte korrekter weise eine
reparatur angeordnet
die ordnungsgemäß durchgeführt wurde
auch wenn es sich um ein minimales
problem handelt wird die abflugzeit um
eine stunde verschoben sicherheit geht
vor die concorde hat bis dahin noch
keine tödlichen unfälle zu beklagen
doch das gilt nicht für alle über
schaftliche
dritter juni
1973 bei der luft schau am flughafen le
bourget das sind zwei herausragende
maschinen ihre muskeln spielen die
concorde und ihr direkter konkurrent die
tu 144 vom russischen flugzeughersteller
tupolew
als die russen erfuhren was die
franzosen und die briten gemeinsam
entwickelt hatten schickten sie die
tupolew ins rennen
der einzige unterschied zwischen den
scheinbaren zwillingen um balance zu
halten hat die tu 144 enten flügel an
der nase ansonsten ist die ähnlichkeit
so frappierend dass industriespionage
gemutmaßt wird im westen nennt man sie
auch abfällig concorde ski
die tupolew erreicht zwei monate vor der
concorde macht 2 ein rückschlag für das
französisch britische projekt ihr erfolg
ist jedoch nur von kurzer dauer denn für
sie ende die flugschau in einer
katastrophe wegen eines
konstruktionsfehlers zerbricht sie
mitten im flug
14 menschen kommen ums leben
die entwickler der concorde geben sich
weiterhin selbstbewusst das unglück sei
auf den hochmut des objekts
zurückzuführen sie seien wie ikarus zu
hoch geflogen
die konstrukteure sind der meinung dass
die concorde so etwas nicht passieren
könne
die concorde ist zwar mit modernster
technik ausgestattet aber sie hat eine
schwachstelle und
zwar beim start der zugleich ihr
markenzeichen ist denn es sieht
spektakulär aus wenn sich die spitze
nase beinahe vertikal in die höhe reckt
jeder start war gerade sie hat mit
voller wucht abgehoben
der schub war so stark dass die
passagiere in ihre sitze gedrückt wurden
das war natürlich aufregend
wenn ich mit der concord geflogen bin
man sich immer zu meinen sitznachbarn
versuchen sie mal aufzustehen das ist
unmöglich
man konnte die beschleunigung am ganzen
körper spüren
die concorde wollte so schnell wie
möglich in die luft dorthin wo sie
hingehört
den kraftvollen start verdammt die
comcom delta flügeln
wie die heutigen hochleistungs kampfjets
besaß auch die concorde delta flügel
delta flügel erzeugen weit weniger
auftrieb als die tragflächen normaler
passagierjet deshalb muss der
steigungswinkel beim stand größer sein
die flügel der concorde erzeugen beim
staat keinen auftrieb
man könnte auf einer startbahn unendlich
stark beschleunigen es würde nichts
bringen
erst wenn der pilot die nase extrem
hochreißt stehen die flügel so im
luftstrom dass der auftritt generiert
wird den man braucht um an höhe zu
gewinnen konnte
[Musik]
dieser ungewöhnlich steilen winkel wirkt
jedoch auch riesig beim abheben wirken
die gesamten 185 tonnen gewicht auf das
heck
[Musik]
die concorde wurde in den 1960 er und 70
er gebaut die reifen der ersten
generation die übrigens auch bei der
boeing 747 verbaut wurden hielten dem
neuen druck nicht so gut stand und
konnten leicht platzen
die reifen der concorde wurden beim
start viel stärker belastet als die
herkömmlicher unter schall flugzeuge
die gefahr dass ein reifen platzt ist
also viel höher als bei normalen
passagierflugzeugen
1979 passiert genau das in dakar ein
reifen der concorde platz beim start
im juni desselben jahres geschieht es
erneut bei einem start am dalles
international airport in washington dc
gummiteile beschädigen drei tanks und
reißen ein großes loch in einen flügel
wie auf diesem bild zu sehen ist
es tritt treibstoff aus und die maschine
muss zum flughafen zurückkehren
der pilot hatte tolle arbeit geleistet
und ist wieder sicher gelandet
damals erregt dieser vorfall kaum
aufsehen
man könnte die sache einfach unter den
teppich eines war jedoch klar die
schwachstelle der concorde waren ihre
reifen
einige jahre später läuft es dann nicht
mehr so glimpflich ab wegen branchen
fünfundzwanzigster juli 2000 flughafen
charles de gaulle es ist 15 uhr im
terminal 1 wird eine reisegruppe langsam
ungeduldig die passagiere wollen endlich
die legendäre concorde f btsc besteigen
die ein deutsches touristikunternehmen
gechartert hat
[Musik]
die concorde steckt seit jahren in
finanziellen schwierigkeiten von anfang
an musste sie mit zwei problemen kämpfen
erstens dem verbot für überschallflüge
über besiedelten regionen das limitiert
die anzahl der flugziele problem nummer
zwei ist der stetig steigende ölpreis
die
concorde war nicht ausgelastet die
franzosen flogen nur die strecke paris
new york und die briten london new york
um mit den maschinen gewinne zu erzielen
wurden weltumrundungen rundflüge und
spezial flüge angeboten
den reisenden ging es gar nicht
unbedingt um die concorde an sich
sondern um das erlebnis mal mit einem
überschallflugzeug zu fliegen
dieser charterflug war von einer
deutschen reederei gebucht worden an
bord waren größtenteils deutsche
touristen die von new york aus mit der
ms deutschland auf kreuzfahrt gehen
wollten
new york ist nur eine zwischenstation
für die 100 köpfige gruppe das ziel
ihrer luxus kreuzfahrt ist ecuador
[Applaus]
es sind also nicht die üblichen
geschäftsleute an bord sondern
passagiere die ihren ruhestand mit einer
ganz besonderen reise feiern
für die meisten soll dieser
überschallflugzeuges erlebnis sein
in kürze werden sie einem elitären kreis
von flugreisenden angehören die 11.000
dollar für einen hin und rückflug kann
sich schließlich nicht jeder leisten
es war die creme de la creme jeder gast
war etwas besonderes und nicht nur eine
nummer man wurde persönlich begrüßt und
sonderwünsche wurden gerne erfüllt
[Musik]
carolin cartier war zehn jahre lang
leitende flugbegleiterin einer concorde
ich durfte täglich bekannte
persönlichkeiten begrüßen von
geschäftsleuten über filmstars bis hin
zu models und politikern
da saßen etwa mick jagger und gérard
depardieu im selben flugzeug
die gäste genießen einen service der
luxushotels gleichkommt h wie java
standard nicht zwar gewöhnlich es gab
reichlich edle weine und exzellenten
champagner es war luxus pur
[Musik]
um 15.40 beginnt das boarding im cockpit
sitzt ein erfahrener pilot
kapitän christian macht die hat über 300
flugstunden mit der concord absolviert
[Musik]
in einer concorde zu fliegen ist nicht
nur für die passagiere ein vergnügen
auch die piloten die sie steuern dürfen
geraten ins schwärmen
john hutchinson war 15 jahre lang
concorde pilot bei british airways
[Musik]
ein wunderschönes flugzeug es war
unbeschreiblich diese maschine zu
fliegen
man konnte sie mit daumen und
zeigefinger steuern als hätte man ein
rennpferd unterm hintern ein englisches
vollblut
die geschwindigkeit wurde einem nur
bewusst wenn man auf der gleichen route
wie ein unterschied flieger unterwegs
war
wenn man 6000 meter unter sich eine 747
sah dachte man die fliegt rückwärts
einfach unglaublich für
[Musik]
mich war es ein traum die concorde zu
fliegen
einfach nur toll als wäre die
schwerkraft ausgehebelt
irgendwie schien man da oben frei atmen
zu können
die concorde ist voll besetzt 100
passagiere sind an bord der legendären
maschinen um 16.25 ist das boarding
abgeschlossen der fluglotse viel los war
wartet auf den funkspruch des piloten
die concorde war kurz vor dem start der
pilot hat sich wie gewohnt beim tower
gemeldet und um die freigabe für den
startgebieten
die concorde ist mit 95 tonnen
treibstoff betankt das ist die hälfte
des gesamtgewichts die 13 tanks sind
randvoll nur so ist der flug über den
atlantik möglich zusammen mit den
passagieren und dem gepäck bringt die
maschine 187 tonnen auf die waage das
entspricht dem zulässigen stadt gelegt
die concorde war voll getankt und voll
beladen die hohe außentemperatur
verstärkte die belastung natürlich noch
die startphase ist immer heikel die
tanks sind voll das gewicht ist also
enorm hoch und die steuerung
schwerfällig deshalb sind abstürze die
beim start passieren meist ziemlich
dramatisch
rösler weiß der concorde startbahn 26
rechts zu mit fast 43 kilometern ist es
die längste des flughafens
fünf minuten vor dem geplanten start
gibt eine andere maschine von der
gleichen startbahn ab es ist eine dc-10
der us-fluggesellschaft continental
airlines und niemand bemerkt dass hier
die nahende katastrophe ihren anfang
nimmt
wie das schicksal es an dem tag wollte
hat die dc-10 auf der startbahn einen
verbogenen metallstreifen verloren
das 43 cm lange teil dient zur
verstärkung eines triebwerks für die
continental ist das nicht
sicherheitsrelevant doch für die
concorde birgt es eine tödliche gefahr
vorerst läuft noch alles nach plan der
fluglotse erteilt den überschalljet die
startfreigabe
nichts wie es auf probleme hin als die
startbahn frei war habe ich grünes licht
gegeben
dann hat der pilot auf der startbahn
beschleunigt
es ist genau 16 uhr 42 und 31 sekunden
wenige sekunden später ist die maschine
kurz davor abzuheben
vom tower aus bewundert die rasante
beschleunigung der concorde
die concorde ist ein eleganter vogel da
muss man einfach jedes mal hinkommen den
anderen fluglotsen geht das genauso
die concorde beschleunigt zweimal
schneller als gewöhnliche flugzeuge ihre
rolls royce olympus turbojet triebwerke
mit den leistungsstarken nach brennern
wurden speziell für sie entwickelt
sie war das einzige kommerzielle
flugzeug das wie kampfjets über
nachbrenner verfügte nachbrenner sorgen
für maximale leistung dahinter der
turbine extra treibstoff eingespritzt
und verbrannt wird
die triebwerke erzeugten 14 tonnen schub
demnach brennen kann man auf 17 tonnen
sie brachten rund 30 prozent mehr
leistung quasi wie ein zusätzliches
triebwerk
32 sekunden nach dem start hat die
maschine mit aktivierten nachbrenner 150
knoten oder
278 km/h erreicht die entscheidungs
geschwindigkeit in der luftfahrt auch v1
genannt nun gibt es kein zurück mehr
alle flugzeuge haben eine entscheidungs
geschwindigkeit sie wird bei jedem start
nach gewicht windstärke und temperatur
berechnet
wenn man bei dieser geschwindigkeit ab
recht kommt man am ende der startbahn
zum stehen
wenn man aber weiter beschleunigt und
dann abbricht schießt man definitiv über
die startbahn hinaus
v1 hebt man ab komme was wolle
wenn nach dem erreichen von v1 ein
problem auftritt muss man das in der
luft lösen
über v1 muss kapitän martin abheben von
dem teil der continental maschine auf
der stadtbahn weiß er nichts als der co
pilot v1 sagt
als der kapitän wie gewohnt vollen schub
der bordmechaniker behält dabei die
triebwerk instrumente im auge
die concorde ist nun mit 300 km h etwa
so schnell wie ein
hochgeschwindigkeitszug
dass die piloten vom cockpit aus nicht
sehen können sie steuern direkt auf den
metallstreifen zu der etwa 18 kilometer
von der startposition entfernt liegt und
die lage dieses metall streifens wird
eine verkettung unglücklicher umstände
in gang setzen
die concorde ist beim beschleunigen über
das metallteil gefahren
[Musik]
auf der 45 meter breiten startbahn
musste der metallstreifen ausgerechnet
dort liegen
zu allem übel ist das teil nicht aus
gewöhnlichem metall wie es eigentlich
der fall sein sollte hier hat ein
verantwortlicher mechaniker eigenmächtig
gehandelt mit fatalen konsequenzen
der mechaniker hatte das teil ein paar
mal ersetzen müssen denn es war mehrmals
abgegangen
er hoffte wohl dass ein deutlich
stabileres teil besser halten würde
titan ist kein gewöhnliches metall
titan ist eine äusserst verschleißfeste
metalllegierung sie wird nur in
bereichen des flugzeugs eingesetzt die
extrem heiß werden titan ist
außerordentlich widerstandsfähig
es hält sengender hitze und hohen
krafteinwirkungen stand auch dem druck
eines flugzeugreifen zu allem unglück
ist der streifen in einer kritischen
position auf der startbahn gelandet
der titan streifen war verbogen und lag
so auf der startbahn
der linke vorderreifen trifft mit 324
km/h auf das teil jetzt tritt das
schlimmste ein was man sich vorstellen
kann
das metallteil drang in den reifen ein
und schlitzte ihn auf und
[Musik]
nimmer tief bei dem hohen druck und der
geschwindigkeit ist es unvermeidbar dass
der reifen zerfetzt wird
das setzt ein horrorszenario in gang als
der reifen platzt wird ein großes gummi
stück gegen die unterseite des flügels
geschleudert
flugzeugreifen sind sehr groß und schwer
das reifen stück hat knapp viereinhalb
kilo gewogen
die genaue rotationsgeschwindigkeit des
reifens kenne ich zwar nicht aber man
kann sich ja gut vorstellen dass dieses
gummi teil nahezu die geschwindigkeit
einer rakete hatte
das reifenteil war riesig und der
aufprall gigantisch
schlug gegen die unterseite des flügels
bei tank 5
die flügel von flugzeugen sind besonders
anfällig von den 13 tanks der concorde
befindet sich nur einer im heck die
anderen zwölf sind auf die delta flügel
verteilt
die flugzeugflügel eignen sich
hervorragend als treibstofflager die
tanks liegen direkt in den flügeln das
wäre sonst vergeudeter stauraum
der aufprall am randvollen tank 5 hat
verheerende folgen des reifen halt
selbst reist zwar kein loch in den tank
aber die hohe krafteinwirkung richtet
großen schaden an
[Musik]
an der stelle des aufpralls im stand
weder eine riss noch ein loch die
erschütterung war jedoch so massiv dass
sie den tank im inneren zum bersten
brachte
der aufprall löste eine druckwelle aus
weil der tank randvoll war konnte die
energie nicht entweichen und entlud sich
an der tankwart die dadurch auf
gesprengt wurde
sprich der tank ist durch die
schockwelle im inneren gerissen der
gummireifen hatte ihn nicht
durchschlagen
wenn man auf einem ballon schlägt platz
der nicht unbedingt an der stelle wo man
drauf haut er kann auch gegenüber oder
an der seite platzen
aus dem klaffenden loch treten unmengen
treibstoff aus
es waren etwa 75 bis 100 liter pro
sekunde
verheerender weise befindet sich das
loch direkt vor den lufteinlässen der
linken triebwerke die können ihren
dienst nicht erfüllen wenn nicht
genügend luft hinein springt
der treibstoff entzündet sich sofort die
genaue ursache dafür ist bis heute
ungewiss es gibt zwei theorien entweder
gab es einen kurzschluss oder der
nachbrenner hat das kerosin entzündet
einige experten gehen davon aus dass
teile des geplatzten reifens die
fahrwerks electric beschädigt oder einen
kurzschluss verursacht haben wodurch
kunden entstanden an denen sich der
treibstoff entzündete
es ist aber auch möglich dass der
treibstoff der nachbrenner die ursache
war der treibstoff ist sicherlich bei
einer stadt geschwindigkeit von 350 km/h
aus dem tank geschossen
so hätte sich vom nachbrenner über den
tank bis zu den triebwerken alles sehr
schnell entzünden können
mit der heißen verschmutzten luft können
die triebwerke nicht korrekt
funktionieren
ein feuer muss keine katastrophe
auslösen wenn aber nur zwei von vier
triebwerken funktionieren lässt sich die
maschine nicht mehr richtig fliegen
der kapitän bemerkt den leistungsabfall
sofort
er wusste dass etwas nicht stimmte als
die concorde nicht wie gewohnt
beschleunigte die rasante beschleunigung
war ja genau ihr markenzeichen dieser
einbruch machte die kuh stutzig
der sonst atemberaubende start schub von
70 tonnen wird an diesem tag
beträchtlich reduziert dann nur zwei
triebwerke funktionieren doch angesichts
der geschwindigkeit hat der pilot keine
wahl
sie machten weiter obwohl die
instrumente für die linken triebwerke
verrückt spielten
der fluglotse china muss die katastrophe
im tower tatenlos mit ansehen
plötzlich habe ich die flammen am heck
der maschine gesehen
ich habe den piloten natürlich sofort
informiert ich sagte air france 4590 sie
haben flammen hinter sich
er sagte nur roger was bedeutet wir
haben verstanden
die concorde hat zu diesem zeitpunkt an
der linken seite ein wahres
flammeninferno hinter sich hergezogen
die luftzufuhr der triebwerke war nun
gleich null
es sah aus wie ein riesiger
flammenwerfer
im cockpit ertönt der feueralarm für
triberg 2 der bordmechaniker aktiviert
den lösch mechanismus trotz des feuers
ist im kapitän bewusst dass er keine
andere wahl hat als abzuheben die
brennende concorde erhebt sich von der
startbahn in die lüfte
[Musik]
es ging alles rasend schnell die
concorde beschleunigte und hob ab und
schon wurden die flammen immer größer
dies ist eines der wenigen bilder der
brennenden concorde
[Musik]
die passagiere haben den rauch sicher
gerochen in einer der toiletten ging
sogar der feueralarm los
das feuer erfasst nun den kompletten
flügel die flammen sind über 2000 grad
heiß
[Musik]
die temperaturen ließen metallteile und
kabel schmelzen
die rolle des linken flügels sind
zerstört nur eine minute nach der
kollision mit dem metallstreifen ist das
flugzeug außer kontrolle
mit nur zwei triebwerken kann es weder
beschleunigen noch aufsteigen
die maschine war verloren sie musste
abheben
doch nach dem triebwerksausfall
erreichte sie gerade mal eine höhe von
60 metern
die sichere stadt geschwindigkeit von
220 knoten war in weiter ferne
die concorde konnte nur mit einer
bestimmten geschwindigkeit ansteigen da
zwei triebwerke ausgefallen waren zog
die maschine nach links deshalb haben
die piloten rechts weniger schub gegeben
wodurch sie noch langsamer wurden
die concorde war kein flugzeug mehr sie
ist wie ein sack kartoffeln durch die
luft geflogen
der fluglotse china versucht alles was
in seiner macht steht um das flugzeug zu
werden
[Musik]
ich hatte keine ahnung was der pilot tun
würde er hätte kreisen umdrehen und
wieder landen können er hätte auch
woanders landen können alles war denkbar
leider ist es für eine rückkehr zum
flughafen zu spät
ihnen war klar dass eine umkehr zum
charles de gaulle technisch
ausgeschlossen war aber sie wussten dass
le bourget in der nähe ist und wollten
es bis dorthin schaffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie sagten wir versuchen das war ja
letzte funkspruch
außer einer großen rauchwolke konnte ich
nicht sehen ich folgte sofort die
concorde ein und sagte france 4590 bitte
kommen
nichts auch nicht nach dem zweiten
versuch dann war klar was passiert war
zum ersten mal in meiner laufbahn hatte
ich den absturz seines flugzeugs gesehen
das wurde mir nun schmerzlich bewusst
nach gerade mal 120 sekunden in der luft
stürzte die concorde auf ein hotel in
gonesse weniger als sechs kilometer von
der startbahn entfernt
kritische pflasterung dies positiv für
disco
der yahoo wo ich sagt christoph kindle
oder sony produkte tresor publikum
tragischerweise bleibt die suche
erfolglos
bei dem absturz starben 113 menschen 100
passagieren neun crewmitglieder und vier
menschen am boden
es ist das ende einer legende nachdem
dieses scheinbar unbesiegbare
überschallflugzeug mitmacht zwei die
welt erobert hat scheitert die
erfolgsgeschichte der concorde in paris
an einem kleinen metallstreifen
flugzeuge stürzen oft auf hoher see oder
in der wüste ab also irgendwo weit weg
aber dass ich so ein unglück direkt vor
unser aller augen ereignen könnte
der absturz der concorde war genauso
spektakulär wie das flugzeug selbst
in den tagen und wochen nach dem unglück
fragen sich viele ob der absturz hätte
verhindert oder vorhergesehen werden
können
[Musik]
der zuständige untersuchungsrichter von
der französischen flugsicherheitsbehörde
bea
beantwortet diese frage mit einem klaren
nein es war eine verkettung
unglücklicher umstände
niemand konnte etwas dafür
natürlich fragt man sich was wäre
gewesen wenn hätten wir etwas tun können
dann wären vielleicht alle noch am leben
die anschließenden ermittlungen haben
jedoch eines klar gezeigt nämlich dass
zu dem zeitpunkt als die crew das
problem bemerkt hatte einen startabbruch
nichts mehr geändert hätte
in dem fall wäre die maschine über die
startbahn hinaus geschossen und dort
verunglückt
da die maschine vollgetankt war wäre das
genauso tragisch ausgegangen
nachdem das metallteil den reifen bei
dem tempo aufgeschlitzt hatte war die
tragödie unvermeidbar
dann
der pilot hat bis zum schluss alles
versucht um die maschine zu retten unter
diesen bedingungen war das flugzeug
nicht mehr manövrierbar
an diesem tag ist leider alles
zusammengekommen sie hatten keine chance
als das flugzeug in der luft war gab es
kein zurück von diesem moment an war das
schicksal der maschine und ihrer
insassen besiegt
der absturz läutet den untergang der
überschall legende ein am tag nach dem
unfall werden aus sicherheitsgründen
alle 14 concorde bis zum abschluss der
ermittlungen aus dem verkehr gezogen
das startverbot wird 14 monate bestand
haben
so lange dauert es die entscheidende
frage zu klären ist die concorde noch
sicher
[Musik]
die luftdichtigkeit der concorde wurde
unter die lupe genommen bis alle zweifel
ausgeräumt waren blieb das startverbot
bestehen
um die behörden und die öffentlichkeit
zu überzeugen werden die maschinen
aufgerüstet die tanks werden mit kofler
ausgelegt eine beschichtung die
druckwellen besser standhält zudem
werden robustere reifen entwickelt im
november 2001 wird der linienbetrieb
wieder aufgenommen doch die buchungen
bleiben aus
das war der anfang vom ende für die
concorde die sitzplatz belegung viel von
ca 80 auf weniger als 20 prozent
die buchungen zurückgehen steigt der
ölpreis unablässig folglich ist die
concorde nicht mehr profitabel im mai
2003 stellt die air france endgültig
alle concorde flüge ein am 21 mai fliegt
die concorde ein letztes mal von new
york nach paris
kauling kg war an dem tag als leitende
flugbegleiterin an bord
als gelandeten und ich zum letzten mal
eine durchsage machte da sah ich dass
einige passagiere tränen in den augen
hatten
sie wussten dass es ihr letzter concorde
flug gewesen war
dieser moment war er eine
liebeserklärung als ein abschied
ich habe die concorde geküsst
im oktober 2003 die british airways nach
es gibt nun keine zivilen
überschallflüge mehr die rückkehr des
legendären flugzeug war nach weniger als
zwei jahren schon wieder ausgeträumt
die concorde hatte ausgedient
bis zu dem absturz hatte sie eine
makellose karriere gehabt doch ihre ära
zu ende der absturz hatte ihren abgang
nur beschleunigt
die concorde ist bis heute ein
meisterwerk der technik aber sie war
veraltet
das futuristische flugzeug aus den 1970
er hat einfach keinen platz mehr in der
luftfahrt des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
heutzutage ist schnelligkeit nicht so
wichtig das design spielt natürlich eine
rolle aber an erster stelle steht die
sicherheit weiter hinter kommen
umweltschutz und günstige preise
die concorde war wieder umweltfreundlich
noch günstig und was die sicherheit
betrifft nun sie hat die standards der
70er jahre erfüllt aber nicht die von
heute
doch die legendären concorde macht bis
heute von sich reden
sie ist zwar nicht mehr am himmel zu
sehen doch es gibt viele stolze
nachfolger
das concord programm war damals für die
französischen und die britischen
entwickler eine fantastische möglichkeit
der ganzen welt ihre fortschritte in der
luftfahrt zu präsentieren
die concorde ebnete den weg für
unzählige innovationen in der modernen
luftfahrt
vor allem hat sie den weg für eine
industrie freigemacht in europa
etabliert wurde
sie wissen bestimmt wovon ich spreche
was sozusagen der samen dem airbus
entwachsen ist
hätten überschallflüge mit der modernen
technik von heute wieder eine chance
viele flugzeughersteller sind davon
überzeugt
die journalistin veronique de mar ist
expertin auf diesem gebiet
um ein neues überschallflugzeug
einzuführen sollte man einen völlig
neuartigen ansatz finden mit viel
fantasie und kreativität
die ingenieure sollten sich richtig
austoben und mit innovativen
technologien experimentieren
das kuriose ist aber dass viele der
neuen prototypen vom design her stark an
die concorde erinnern
airbus kooperiert bei der entwicklung
des überschallflugzeugs der zukunft mit
us amerikanischen start ups
airbus und entwickeln gemeinsam einen
überfall business jet für acht bis zwölf
passagiere der code name lautet as2 der
kommerzielle name wird vielleicht etwas
ansprechender der jungfernflug ist für
2021 geplant und kommerzielle flüge ab
airbus hat bereits ein patent für eine
maschine angemeldet die von paris nach
new york nur eine stunde benötigt das
wäre dreimal schneller als die concorde
der 70er jahre
ob es je wieder ein überschall
verkehrsflugzeug geben wird oder nicht
für viele ist und bleibt die concorde
einzigartig und unvergesslich